hi and welcome to episode number 26 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark hey
France sku doing today very good very
happy and very excited about the
interview to Gustavo Gustavo ambrosio
guest I've ambrosio from pocket gems is
here today to talk about their game war
dragon and how their back-end
infrastructure works yeah i love the
talk that you gave with him geez be next
I thought it was a very it was a very
interesting talk because there was a lot
of interesting technical aspects and
also a bunch of dragons so that's always
good whenever there's dragons that's
awesome yep and he's back to basically
tell us a little bit more about all the
details and all the things behind behind
the scenes on what is the name were of
dragons war dragons were dragons yeah
what one of dragons that wars name I
like we're trying for dragons yeah and
after that we're gonna be talking about
go yeah we have a nice follow-up
question from one of our listeners
hearin who is one of our I think more
prolific commenters on the podcast yeah
I challenge anyone to beat him for a
number of comments we should send him a
t-shirt like we said he'll have not done
it yet he's been on the podcaster yeah
he deserves a t-shirt maybe two yeah but
before that we're going to be talking
about the cool thing of the week as
often and it's actually a very
interesting cool thing of the week and
its sins dotnet was open source some
time ago this effort has now been doable
which is you can now run net done
multiplications on Google cloud platform
yeah this is pretty cool I know some
people be like but wait couldn't I have
just spun up a Windows instance before
and done this myself regardless but I
think the cool thing is is we've got now
dotnet client libraries for connecting
to things like cloud datastore and other
services that we have so you want to not
just run just regular old applications
but you want to interact with some of
the managed services we have I think
that's a really really cool offering
yeah there's a blog post and we'll put a
link to it on the show notes but
basically the important thing that I
thing it's very exciting is the fact
that you if you lie rotting definite
applications that you really know how to
do it now you can still do it and be
that and use some of the infrastructure
that Google cloud platform offers so one
of them is Google Cloud datastore we
talked about many times so basically
this way of basically deploying storing
data that scales is completely managed
to you have to care about it there is a
bunch of examples there's a helloworld
tutorial there's a bookshelf tutorial
but basically give it a try and let us
know what you think about it yeah
that'll be great okay so I guess it's
time to go and talk to ambrosio ah keep
on changing his name I guess it is last
names yeah so mr. ambrosio there we go
Gustavo yeah let's go chat with Gustavo
thanks so much to Gustavo ambrosio I
would joining us today lead software
engineer at pocket gems and one of the
genius brains behind war dragons how are
you doing today well I'm doing better
now that I'm a genius I didn't know that
yeah thank you thank you for that thanks
for having me more than happy to give
compliments like that so thanks so much
for coming to talk to us today about
pocket gems about war dragons about the
game itself but why don't you tell us a
little bit about who you are what you do
or that sort of good stuff so yeah I've
been I'm a software engineer have been a
software engineer for I don't know how
long I started when I was 15 even before
college I started programming and today
I'm 42 so you do the math there I I
don't think I've ever done anything else
in my life I love it and mostly I've
worked in Brazil on non gaming related
stuff some boring corporate stuff and
then at some point I started coming here
q to San Francisco a lot and I just I
wanted to move here I was like this is
my place this is where you know software
engineers have to come is the you know
it's kind of like the the your body
politic of the mecca the mecca yeah so I
decided to come here so I started
looking for a job and I found Paco Jemez
they interviewed me they hired me they
gave me a visa so I moved and I've been
working there for the last three and a
half years making making games and
having fun and yeah and you know
creating stuff it's awesome I love it
excellent um so I know that you've been
behind a game called war dragons yeah
just had some pretty decent success yes
we did wonderful I do you want to tell
us a little bit about the game what it's
about what's the style of game or that
sort of fun stuff ok so the game wore
dragons is a highly polished 3d realtime
strategy mobile game where you collect
and control hundreds of dragons to take
out enemy bases in short you get to
control a lot of awesome looking dragons
then blow up a lot of stuff it was
pocket gems first 3d game with real-time
synchronous multiplayer battles and our
first game to come out with social
features from day one features like chat
guilds forums leaderboards all of that
there's the first game that on day one
we had that its development wise was our
longest game from start to release we
never had a game that had that size
before we never had a game that had the
size of the team that we have right now
so it's a great learning experience for
us at pocket gems they have to create a
view a new 3d engine we had to create a
lot of real-time communication stuff for
for mobile it was a really exciting
project to work on cool so I wanted to
add also since you just showed us that
on top of having so many cool features
you also have a very cool add and I
thought it was amazing thank you yeah
we'll put that on the show notes it is
it is super cute and creepy at the same
time yeah we're trying to to reach an
audience of like this is a supposed to
show and like Comedy Central and ESPN so
you imagine you're like a person like 30
years old and you're watching ESPN and
that thing comes on it's like it's kind
of weird you have to watch it you
understand what I'm saying but it's
probably going to get your attention a
little bit yeah we'll put in the show
notes that's for sure I think definitely
it's definitely worth watching it's
hilariously made me that way we like it
we like it cool so you said he was on
it's an android game and I'm I'm
interested on the Android salivate too
but could you explain a little bit about
since it's an android game what is the
part on the cloud like
why are using a clown how so it's an
android and iOS we started with iOS we
just released our android version
roughly a month ago and the cloud
basically allows us to we need a cloud
you do all the social features we need
the cloud because it's a it's a game
where in everybody's basis matter and
everything like you can affect the game
of other players it's very connected
game we need to have that connectivity
we need to have all the cloud to support
those features so it's very very heavily
based on the cloud like we have a lot of
features that are based on the cloud we
like to release new events for example
every every week we have like special
events and all of our special events are
heavily based on on cloud technology
they're not built on the phone we have
something very generic on the phone and
then we can just push different
different events every week just using
our cloud technology it also allows us
to have Android and iOS players at the
same playing together at the same time
so it doesn't matter if you're playing
Android you're playing iOS you you're
going to battle people with within other
platforms as well cool and it also
allows you to do a lot of stuff with
analytics as well doesn't it yeah we've
been doing analytics on the cloud for
like since the beginning of pocket gems
like basically this we always have a lot
of heavy analytics on the cloud for all
of our games right so we have already
this built into all of our games we have
a common platform that every game sends
all their events and all the data that
we need to figure out where users
enjoying here or users not enjoying the
right we'd use it you do a/b testing to
see if a new feature is something that
the users are going to like or not and
then we decide to to release features
based on on that data cool are you also
using analytics not only for features
but also to like analyze performance and
stuff like that yeah so one a part of
the analytics that we do is collect
performance from from devices so you
know like we can split by the Vice type
and by platform and we know
what places of the game are slowing down
the user or places they're using too
much memory so we can also use that data
to drive our development to make our
game perform faster have you know better
fps we're always trying to have like
very smooth animation and it's which is
really hard with the range of devices
that we work with like if you have a
very high-end device it's easy to do
that but when you go to the lower end
devices that we still want to support
because do a lot of people are using
those devices it becomes really really
hard and having all that data to help us
focus on an area of the game that we
need to improve performance and make the
game smoother for everyone great so
obviously you've got a back-end
infrastructure you're on our podcast
which probably means you're using google
cloud platform yes you want to tell us a
little bit about like sort of what
back-end infrastructure using how using
it that sort of stuff yeah we've been
using Google App Engine heavily since
the beginning of pocket gems so like
from the first game that when you know
our founders were the company was just
two people that you founders they start
using google app engine and we we
haven't looked back like Google App
Engine has worked for us really really
well and has continued to work with
every game that we build so use Google
App Engine a lot we use a data store a
lot we use probably every feature that
google app engine has to offer we are
using in in very different ways very we
think innovative ways that we've used
Google App Engine there's a I don't know
if you want to mention the talk we did a
DCP next definitely yeah so there's that
that talk we talk about a lot about that
if we go into some more like technical
details we have some interesting tricks
that we use that pocket gems to be able
to run our games in a smooth way in the
cloud so I think we're also going to put
that on the on the show notes cool so
something occurs about and I always ask
this question every single time I see
people doing real time how are you doing
it on App Engine so the part of our real
time we're using a company called pub
nub so a pub nub does a lot of real-time
stuff as well so because we already had
a partnership with them with SATA G
that for real time so and I don't know
what they have in in their back end okay
to be honest but we do some stuff which
is near real-time and Google App Engine
it's it it has low latency so you can do
stuff like that if you're using in a
clever way like we do a lot of stuff
that requires us to be real time like
all the battle reports and know whenever
you're fighting someone you need to
distribute yeah resources that's all
done using a google app engine cool so
you're essentially doing like all your
user data and your game data and like
your matchmaking all that stuff's in App
Engine yeah all that all that part is in
App Engine yeah matchmaking whenever you
need to battle someone like to figure
out who is a good user for you to battle
because like we have millions of users
and some of them have super strong bases
and some of them have super you know
week basis because it just started
playing so you need to figure that out
that is all done using Google App Engine
we have leaderboards which is also very
computationally heavy we use that on
Google App Engine actually using some
code that google released as open source
for leaderboards so we found that when
we're building our leaderboard tech and
we said yeah let's let's use that so we
started using that and we modify that a
little bit to suit our needs but that's
the base of our leaderboard what else is
very complicated there well all the game
user data we do support people playing
in multiple devices that's also done
through the clouds whenever you you know
quit your game we save all your data in
the cloud and if you load that game and
another device we load all that data
from the clouds or that game game state
management is done on on Google App
Engine all our a be testing is done
using Google App Engine we can release
new dragons for example without
releasing a new version of the game we
can do something like that and it's all
done using Google App Engine even our
our asset management is done using
Google App Engine and using the google
runnin cash it's really fast for us cool
so i'm assuming that when you say Google
App Engine 4 to store data you're
actually using the data store
for the files I'm not sure how we're
doing that okay I'm not sure if it's
google data store i think it is actually
using google data store to be cloud
storage maybe yeah i'm not sure that
part i don't know that part is really
really like we built that in the
beginning i never had that cold isn't
working for us for like six years I he
just works yes just been working forever
that is good yeah so um obviously you've
had some success how have you had to
like change how your application has
been built since been running on App
Engine running on datastore have you
needed to make many changes to it as you
the scale of how many loads and how many
players any games and battles have grown
no we haven't like at least since I
started working with pocket gems this
has been working like wonderfully we
never had to worry about our servers
going down and all of that it just
things just work when we released war
dragons we've we had like big spikes
that I it's shown in that presentation
you can see the big spikes that we had
in like number of battles i think is the
the graph that i had there and we didn't
have to touch anything we didn't have to
you know call google and say hey we're
going to have a big big spike here so
you guys better be ready no it's it's it
works and you know it scales up and
scales down as you need it and things
just work we have we had a few
adjustments that we did basically to
control the costs that we have in Google
App Engine so there's some stuff that we
were doing and the way that we designed
it he was using like too much too much
data or it was usually he was doing too
many datastore calls so we redesigned a
few of those things to do less calls and
still had the same functionality to
drive our costs down I believe you are
using memcache a lot to do that right we
use memcache to do that it's also in the
presentation if people want one some
detail on how we do that it's a very
clever way to use memcache and that data
store and task queues so we use all that
technology and we were able to drive our
costs down a lot great i'm also really
curious I mean you just released android
you've had my OS version out for a long
time did you have to change the app
engine code at all for each individual
like platform for your mobile platform
is it the same or what happened there
not at all it doesn't change anything we
have like you can imagine we have a
bunch of client code that we say if is
Android do this if its iOS do this but
on on our platform side on the google
app engine side i don't believe we have
any of that and if that all the
communication is done completely the
same cool could you could you tell us a
bit about how you're doing it is a REST
API or it's mostly rest api like it's
really easy to build a REST API is on
top of Google App Engine so we mostly
use restful api s with a few exceptions
there for example for just to get files
this is not rest is just plain old HTTP
there's not a lot of stuff going on
there but for all the data communication
is all doing a rest and with json as the
as the the format that we we send back
and forth and it's really easy to use on
the mobile side as well like there's you
know millions and thousands of of
libraries out there that's going to do
that for you right out of the box
without using anything like crazy so the
question that I always ask to four
people have Rikard on App Engine are you
ready needing go sorry is it ready dingo
what is the language that use we use
Python Python yeah we use Python it's
fine it's fine no i phone is awesome i
love Python I haven't written anything
in go so I'm not gonna not gonna bad
mouth it excellent um so you do some
really interesting things we covered
this in in our presentation but I'd like
to go over it again because i think it
was really clever how you use App Engine
versions and match those up to client
versions George talk a little bit about
how that works sure so you know google
app engine versions say for people that
don't know it's basically you can deploy
various versions of your code in Google
App Engine then cool app in is going to
give you a different URL for every
version that you have traditionalist is
used for testing so if I'm a developer
and I'm developing a new feature I don't
want to keep deploying that to
production so we deploy that to a
different
version of Google App Engine and then I
can test that using that different URL
right without disturbing production code
but at pocket gems we devise the
difference use for that so whenever we
release a new version on on mobile what
happens is sometimes we have to break
compatibility with the previous version
of Google App Engine and traditionally
people have been doing that with if else
if else if version is this dualistic
versions that do that and then you end
up with a lot of code that is old code
and awful to read right so we don't like
that so we do is we basically whenever
we releasing a new version of google app
engine we don't care about breaking
compatibility and what we do is when we
released a new version of the game we
first deploy that the version for the
new version we deploy in a different URL
and we configure our client code to go
to that URL instead so then when people
start downloading that new version they
go to the new version of google app
engine and the old version still go to
the old version so we don't break
compatibility there like it all works
for everyone and then at some point what
we do is we force users to upgrade so a
few days after we release something we
force users to upgrade then everybody
upgrades and we were able to take down
the old version and now the new version
becomes what it's called a default
version and everybody just connects to
that to that version so we're able to
very easily break compatibility without
actually breaking anything that is very
cool I guess that that's the power of
being able to force clients to be
updated that is yeah yeah we didn't have
to do that like we only do that because
also we sometimes break compatibility
between in battle so when you're
battling people online with the new
version might have a different spell
that we created and then if you know if
I'm fighting you when you have the old
version and I and I do that spell that
spells not going to work on your end so
now things become out of sync so we
break compatibility basically not
because of server code like if you think
about cervical we could just keep like
10 versions running there yeah right it
doesn't it
it wouldn't cost as much or anything
else I think more and it's not not you
wouldn't be such a big deal but there's
this client part that does break
compatibility when people are playing
with each other online that would break
so that's why we force people to do a
basically that is interesting otherwise
people could use the the strategy of I'm
not gonna have great so no one can
attack me yeah but then you can't attack
anyone and yeah yeah you lose a lot if
you don't do that and the social aspect
of the game i think is one of the most
important parts we've been seeing that
that social aspect of it is what drives
people back like we have guilds do so
you everybody's part of a guild and your
guild just placed together to fight
other guilds and your guild members can
help you when you attack with with their
dragons so that aspect is really
important for for everyone so you can
see people whenever we release a new
version I get a message from my guild
leader saying hey you should upgrade
your game because otherwise we can't
help you and you know so upgrade right
now so we can all still help each other
so it's really it's really that aspect
is really nice so upgrading is important
for for users not just for us great so
obviously we I mean obviously but we
also covered this in the presentation
but again I thought this is really
interesting you use like a data store
and some really interesting ways to do
matchmaking we're gonna talk a little
bit how that process works I know you
also use task queues and some other fun
stuff yeah so for matchmaking it's kind
of a complicated thing because what I
said before you have millions of users
and every user is going to have a
different level so what we created
basically we created a concept of
bucketing users into matchmaking like
similar matchmaking levels so whenever
you do something that changes what your
power would be like for example you
upgraded a building or you upgraded a
dragon or you just applied some some
different what we call room to a dragon
for example your powers change their you
become more powerful and whenever
something like that happens we put a
task in the task queue to basically
recalculate what bucket you should be in
and then at some point that task you
runs we recalculate your power and we
see in what bucket is better for you to
be and then we place you in that bucket
that bucket now like you had that bucket
now it's something that whenever you
want to battle someone we just go to
that bucket and we pick some player
that's in that bucket we know that
they're going to have a very similar
very similar level to you so the battle
is going to be challenging it's not
going to be something that's going to be
super easy for you to beat or it's going
to be impossible for you to beat we know
that you know it's possible to be you're
going to lose some you're going to win
some but it's possible but with millions
of users we couldn't find on a better
way to better way to do that and still
be like perform well right because
whenever you battle this one of the most
important things we need to respond
really fast we want to want you to go
into battle as fast as we can so if we
have to wait for you know the server
tube to come back with something and it
takes five seconds it's gone like your
users already out of the game by that
point great so you're able to leverage
task queues to be able to push that into
the background so that the user doesn't
have to wait for it and we can keep that
data that complicated data processing
happening in the background yeah and
it's not that important to change your
bucket right then right you can wait a
few seconds your your previous bucket
it's still competitive is still very
similar to what you are right you're not
going to be super easy so if we if it
takes 5-10 seconds to change your your
bucket it's not a big deal so we can we
just push that to the task queue and the
test q does that calculation for us in
the background excellent cool so I think
that we're actually running out of time
but as always we'd like to give you the
opportunity of telling us whatever you
feel like we left out I just want to say
that we are we're hiring engineers right
now we're hiring especially we're trying
to we're looking for managers and leads
it's really it's a hard position to fill
so take a look at our website we're
going to have that in the inner notes I
believe as well yep take a look there
and if you're interested just contact me
it's gustavo wet pocket gems calm if
you're around for google i/o if you want
to come and visit the office and you
know just shoot me an email you can come
we're
you're in the city pretty close to you
to where the conference is going to be
I've been up the offices the offices are
very nice yeah yeah we have a very nice
office thank you I have not been invited
yet you're just saying officially
officially invite it now cool yeah
whenever you want to come yeah so you
have that position open we're also going
to be here for I'm going to be a ww see
if you here for wwc just look me up as
well we can we can chat we're happy to
have you in the office and show you
around cool well thank you so much for
taking the time today to come to the
office and talk to us thanks for having
me your office is also really awesome
thank you geez thank you very much
Gustavo for such a great interview I
learned a lot and I saw a lot of dragons
on the video you should definitely check
it out again that ad is very very funny
yes but we are almost about to finish
the episode but we will not finish
before the question of the week and the
question of the week as we said it's
coming from here in patel yeah he
messaged just after listening to our
episode and was quite interested in go
but hadn't played with it he comes from
a path and background with immediately
curious about web frameworks in go it's
a common question I've heard it
definitely a few times before yeah yeah
it's actually very it's a very
interesting question because especially
for people coming from Python and even
more coming from Ruby they tend to miss
these frameworks such as if you can for
Ruby you know there's Ruby on Rails yep
if you're coming from Python there you
know this jungle yeah if you're writing
go what what yep yeah so there's
actually my advice on this is frameworks
so the first thing to understand is
actually difference between what a
framework and a toolkit is and while in
many languages you're going to be
finding frameworks such as Ruby on Rails
is clearly a framework frameworks will
force you to adapt your code to whatever
they feel the code should look like so
that is something that if that is what
you're trying to follow that story fine
and if you use case matches what you're
providing then it's great yep now when
you try to modify it may be really hard
so instead
the NGO community tries to drive towards
its took it so you have a bunch of
toolkits you have things like my
favorite one is gorilla love gorilla
yeah it's a web framework is very very
simple and basically you can pick and
choose whatever you need to use so you
have like oh I need to use a different
way of routing request to my web
handlers there's a way of doing that
there i need to do sessions or whatever
like there's a bunch of different tiny
packages that basically you can add to
your code and they they integrate very
well with the standard Ned HTTP package
so that is great and if you want to know
more about others there's actually a
bunch of them we will put a link to a
post from last year from the new stack
that basically they cover five go
frameworks and there's Big O which is an
actual framework there's martini which
is a very lightweight framework that
uses a lot of reflection this is like
kind of like trying to be like go on
Rails and it did not work that well so
the the author of the framework Jeremy
signs hi Jeremy he created a second
version it's called neck Ronnie's much
seemed pretty much more lightweight so
if you think about during using
something that's out nagrani is also
very good option there's go craft and
then there's also gorilla so check it
out and also there's a very good talk
from my friend I lost the link mark fet
from my friend mark dates he used to be
rubios and basically he gave a talk at
Gotham go two years ago and the talk was
about okay so where he's gone rails and
he basically answers that question so
the name of the talk is everything
you're you've always wanted to know
about go web apps but we're afraid to
ask and of course we'll have the link to
that on the show not soon no it sounds
great I think I mean we talked a little
bit about it but I think the standard
library has defined such a nice set of
like standard interfaces and waiter like
wastes like interact and manipulated
that I feel like the NGO community is
more about composable libraries and like
composable toolkits to build the
eventual software than you need then
rather than building one huge monolith
of opinionated framework so that is that
is actually something that I really
appreciate it and I'm thinking about
maybe writing about it is about the
power of very simple interfaces and how
they allow you to extend the behavior of
the existing code right so if you think
about it the HTTP package has these
interface yeah handler that has only one
method service to be super simple yeah
but that actually powers all the other
tokens yeah and it's in you know make
that super super powerful it's very
unique see Brett you write the one tool
for one thing and then you pop it to
another thing another thing another
thing yeah interfaces like the pipes of
go yeah why not why not I could say the
channels are the types of yeah yeah yeah
both whatever but yeah anyway check the
video take the pop the the blog post and
let us know what you think about it
absolutely and before we leave I think
it's important to mention the fact that
we are in our cool thing of the week you
might have heard it like yesterday a lot
of cool things going on at Google i/o
yep we will be covering them during next
episode until then just you can check
the videos and everything is being yeah
not often source stream live stream live
streamed if you check the hashtag hash
io 16 I'm sure there'll be plenty of
content I think it's gonna be hard not
to to find out all the new things before
next week but in the meanwhile I'm
hoping you will find them at our final
round and we'll cover them next week and
next week we'll be talking with John
Fenella yeah we're going to have a
interesting chat about unit kernels
which is something up and coming it
keeps popping up in conversations so
we're gonna have a good deep
conversation about that yep so if you're
curious about you need kernels tune in
next week great alright well we'll
definitely be it i oh well now without
cause i knows right now where are you
going to be after that so i'm going to
be so by next week i will be in chicago
for go to and after that
I'm going to try to relax well actually
as I said I'm going to be biking from
San Francisco to LA its life cycle but
in the meanwhile I'm going to be
preparing my talk for july in Gopher
come oh yes yeah and today I got a very
exciting piece of news which is I will
be doing the opening keynote hmm I am
very excited i canna canis carried to be
doing the opening keynote gopher come
when one of the speakers literally
created the language rough i will be
there to speaking son no pressure just
never pressure no retro but yeah super
excited about that opportunity excellent
I think my big ones coming up a june
third here at the google SF office we
are having the change the cloud summit
so if you're interested in building
games and interacting with the cloud
either from a multiplayer a possibly
analytics perspective definitely sign up
we'd love to have you come and hang out
with us for a day cool well thanks so
much again for taking the time to record
these episode with me today thank you
for taking the time to record it with me
and Doc to your next week see you next
week
you